peace talks aimed at ending nearly four
years of civil war in Yemen are underway
in Sweden the fighting between a
saudi-led coalition and Iranian backed
rebels has killed more than 10,000
people and pushed millions to the brink
of famine the u.s. supplies weapons and
intelligence to Saudi forces Elizabeth
Palmer is the only US network
correspondent inside Yemen she visited a
refugee camp in southern Yemen Elizabeth
good morning good morning I'm in a
refugee camp where about two and a half
thousand people live and every one of
them is here because they've fled
fighting elsewhere in Yemen
they've always been poor but now they
are destitute living in the most
rudimentary shelter bits of wood
tarpaulins of course they have no proper
access to medical care the only family
for example can't get help for their
six-year-old daughter who has a really
severe neurological problem and just a
few weeks ago a child here died of
cholera the sanitation here is
dangerously bad there are a few latrines
but most people just use the fields and
yet people here are getting just about
enough food to eat and that's more than
you can say for 14 million other Yemenis
the number of people the United Nations
now says is at the risk of extreme
hunger or even starvation this winter
preceding I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Mushaf
a refugee camp in Yemen two massive
humanitarian crisis there Elizabeth
Palmer reporting from Yemen and I'm glad
she's there to remind us exactly what
some of the conditions are on the ground
the war that is going on the war that
the US has helped aid and that will be a
debate in Congress about whether to
continue that tens of thousands of
children have been killed